go ahead thank you jen just following up
on this very basic but very important
question
you're telling us that the dhs chief has
the most recent numbers about how many
of these patients under the bridge have
been sent back and how many have been
released into the u.s the dhs chief is
telling us that he doesn't know so who
else can we ask
you can certainly ask the department of
homeland security i am confident peter i
am confident he wanted to have the most
up-to-date numbers and we will venture
to get you those i promised you this
afternoon is this an issue of not
knowing or is this an issue of a lot
more people are being released into the
us than are being sent out
that is certainly not the issue first i
think it's important to reiterate what i
conveyed earlier about
what the actual process is
individuals are expelled under title 42
if they can't be expelled under title 42
they are put into a removal process if
they are put into a removal process
they're either transported to an ice
facility or released with a legal
document that legal document includes
fingerprints photos phone numbers an
address in the united states and a
background check that's the process that
transpires that's a part of our
immigration process regardless of where
you're coming from just because you keep
using title 42
to defend this administration's
immigration policies that is a trump era
regulation you guys came in saying that
the trump era immigration policy was
very inhumane title 42 is not an
immigration policy it is a it is a
health authority because we're in the
middle of a pandemic the trump
administration approach to immigration
was inhumane and was immoral that's why
we need to put a new policy in place and
we need congress to pass that policy
unified control democratic control of
congress
many months in office you have not even
tried
that's not actually true there's been a
peter just just factual here there's
been there's been a bill proposed first
day in office currently it was proposed
as a part of steps were proposed as part
of the reconciliation process right the
parliamentarian rejected that proposal
they're going back and proposing new
options president supports that he would
like to see immigration reform pass into
law more humane processes
has president biden ever been to the
southern border
in his life yes i will have to get look
back in my history books and check the
times he's been to the southern we have
been looking all morning and we cannot
find any record of him visiting the
border as president vice president
senator or even as a concerned citizen
why would that be
i can check and see when the last time
or when he may have been but but tell me
more about why you're asking because
this is a president who makes a point
when there are disasters in this country
like a wildfire or
a hurricane to go and see for himself
firsthand what the needs are of the
local community so that he can have an
informed
pov to make policy why doesn't he do
that why doesn't he go down to del rio
texas and see what's going on well first
of all peter i think the situation at
the border is the result of a broken
system and the president certainly
relies on his experience so whether it
was the work he did to address root
causes as vice president
his efforts when he was in the senate to
support comprehensive immigration
reform a steps that at a time were done
being done and worked toward in a
bipartisan way something that uh
certainly we think should be the case
today he uses all of his experiences to
inform how he governs how he approaches
challenges and certainly he looks again
at the last four years and the the
separation of children who are ripped
from the arms of their parents as a way
he does not want to proceed so all of
his experiences and his time in office
whether vice president or senate uh
inform his approach to issues i'm steve
ducey i'm brian kilmeade and i'm ainslie
earhardt and click here to subscribe to
the fox news youtube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis